The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: Self-driving
cars are pretty cool.
It's pretty hot
nowadays, so we're going
to use this as an example.
And in the past we have seen
how we can give an autonomous
vehicle a goal-- some
condition we want it to reach.
For example, we
might have a car that
wants to pick up some
passengers along the way,
get to some destination, and
maybe navigate some worlds.
But let's consider
that for something
like a self-driving car, we also
have a number of other goals
or requirements that are sort of
implicit along the way, in that
we want our self-driving car
to obey the rules of the road
as it's driving.
And these aren't
just goal conditions
which is a sort of single goal
that you're trying to reach,
but these are sort
of goals that you're
trying to maintain throughout
the path that you're traveling.
So one example of this
is a traffic light.
So maybe you guys can
help me out with this.
Just in plain
English, how would you
describe the rules
of how you would
want a car to behave when it
comes across a traffic light?
Anything?
It's very simple.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Slow down when you see
yellow, stop when you see red,
go if you see green.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So pretty much stop if you
see red, go if you see green,
and specifically, if you
see red and you stop,
you're going to want
to stop until you
see the green, at which
point that sort of condition
that you're stopping goes away,
and you're able to move on.
And in addition to things
like obeying traffic lights,
there might also be some
other rules of the road
that we want to follow.
For example, we might
want to always stay
within the speed limit.
And then there might also be
some other practical conditions
of driving down the road,
which is that at some point
we're going to need to refuel.
And if we consider
a car that might
be driving for a really long
time, one logical statement
we could say about the
path that this car takes,
and the sequence of states
that it goes through
is that at every
point in time we
want the plan to have some
future state when we are
going to visit a gas station.
So this isn't just a single
goal that we're trying to reach,
but over a very long
time, even if we consider
the car to be driving an
infinite amount of time,
at every point in
the time, we're
going to be thinking
ahead that there's
going to be some time when we
reach a gas station and refuel.
So these types of
conditions, things
like staying at a red
light until it turns green,
always staying within
a certain speed limit,
or always having some
path in the future--
some state in the future
when we reach a gas station,
are things that we can
express with a type of logic
called temporal logic.
And there are two
things that we hope
you're going to be able
to do by the time you
leave this lecture.
The first is be able to model
these temporally extended goals
using a specific type
of temporal logic called
Linear Temporal Logic, or LTL.
And secondly,
we're going to hope
that you'll be able to actually
apply this to planning, create
plans with these
temporally extended goals,
and in addition just sort
of this regular planning
we've been dealing with,
actually incorporating
this idea of preferences
into your plans.
So a preference basically
is not a required condition,
but a desired condition
that you can use to select
between alternative paths.
So you know, you might have many
different ways that you could
reach your goal,
but we can use some
of these temporally
extended goals,
like maybe you prefer to break
as few of the rules of the road
as you can, and you can use
those a preferences to choose
between plans.
So just as an
outline, first we're
just going to do a
little introduction
to linear temporal logic.
We're going to talk
about what this
is-- what LTL is, why
we want to use it,
and we're going to go through
the syntax and the semantics
of different LTL operators.
Then we're going to walk
you through some example LTL
problems, and actually talk
about complications to plans--
how you create plans with
these linear temporal logic
and temporal goals.
Finally we're going to
incorporate preferences
into this, talk about how
you express preferences,
and specifically talk
about a language called
LPP that allows you to plan with
temporal logic and preferences.
So now for the introduction
to linear temporal logic.
Temporal logic at its
core is a formalism
for specifying properties of
a system that vary with time.
So these aren't
just conditions that
are true at single
state, which is
what we've mostly been dealing
with prepositional logic.
Right, so we've been saying
things like, condition A and B,
but not C, are true
at a given state,
and that's prepositional logic.
Temporal logic is
sort of a layer on top
of that, when we're dealing
not just with what's
true at a single state, but
actually extending over time
as the system moves through
a sequence of states,
and expressing properties
on a temporal level.
So you might have a system that
can be represented as a state
machine, and a
[INAUDIBLE],, and it
can go through a sequence
of different states.
And while you might be able
to represent the whole system
like this, if we actually
execute the system
we're going to get one
path through the system.
And that's often called
a trace of the system,
and you can also think of it
as a timeline of the system.
So one example
timeline of this system
is it might start
in state A, and then
go to state C, and then go to
D, and keep looping around in D
forever.
So that's one trace, or
one timeline of the system,
and that's really just
a sequence of states
that it goes through.
And in the past we've seen these
in some of the problem sets.
For example when we were
modeling the warp reactor,
we had the valves
that could transition
between open and closed states.
It could also be
the whole system--
the starship going
through different planets,
transitioning through a
larger set of locations,
picking up passengers,
dropping them off.
So these could be quite complex.
And so as I said,
previously in our problems
that we've been modeling, we've
been going through a system,
and we've been searching for
a single state that satisfies
all of our goal conditions.
Maybe we to reach
[? Lavinia ?] and save
a certain number of people.
But with temporal
logic, we can actually
express goals that are satisfied
over a number of states,
and this allows us to do
some more expressive goals
than we could capture
just by looking
at a single state at the end.
So for example,
what if a problem
requires some
condition to be met
until another condition is met?
And for example, you know,
when you see a red light,
that implies that we should
stop until we see a green light.
And if we look at a
timeline, or a trace of one
of these systems, that might
look something like this.
So we're going along
through our system,
and at one of the states,
we see the red light.
So that adds this condition
that we should stop.
And then that condition
will hold forever
until we see a green
light, at which point
that condition is dropped,
and we can keep moving on.
Another example where we might
want to use temporal logic
is, what if our problem
requires a condition
to always eventually be met.
And this is what I was talking
about with the gas station.
So we want to be
going on forever,
and there should always be
some point in the future
when we do have a state
where we're at a gas station.
So we might start our
system at a certain state.
And our plan says
that at some point
we do reach a gas
station, so that's good.
But then when we get
to the next state,
we also want it to be
true that from that point
on, we're going to reach another
gas station, and after that,
going on and on and
on into the future.
These are things that you
can't express very easily
with the types of logic that
we've been dealing with before.
So one important distinction
that we should clear up
before we really dive
into the syntax of how
these linear
temporal logics work
is the difference between
branching time and linear time.
They're really two
different models of time
that we can be working with.
There's two different
types of temporal logic
that exist to express these
different types of time.
So linear time is more
similar to the world
that we live in, unless you're
living in some sci-fi movie
where time is branching
into different realities,
and all sorts of crazy
stuff is going on.
You can think of time as
just this linear timeline.
So right now, it's
one future state
that's going to happen for me.
And you know, regardless
of how many options I have,
there's one realization
of the time.
And what this lets us
do is that it gives us
a single path for our system,
and we can reason very exactly
about the conditions that
are met within that path.
And this lets us describe what
will always happen in a system.
For example, we can
guarantee that we always
stop at a red light until
we see a green light,
or we always stay
within the speed limit.
This is contrasted with a
different model of time,
called branching time.
And in this model of time,
at each time instant,
we consider all
possible futures.
So if we have multiple
actions that we could perform
at a given state, we're going
to consider different timelines
that branch off for each of
those possible behaviors.
And this results in
alternate courses of time
that we can reason
about as a set.
And instead of thinking about
this as always conditions-- so,
our path always
does this-- we can
think about this more
in possibilities.
And if we're using branching
time, we can say, you know,
at this state and time,
there exists a future path
in which we will always
stay under the speed limit,
or, at this point in time,
all our future paths satisfy
a certain condition.
So whereas linear
temporal logic is
more about guaranteeing what
will happen on a given path,
branching time
allows us to reason
about what might possibly
happen in the system.
So for our purposes
with planning,
in part because it's
more attractable,
and in part because it gives
us an exact analysis of a given
path, we're going to
be doing linear time,
and for that reason,
we use what's
called linear temporal logic.
There's a different
type of temporal logic.
There's one called CTL and CTL*
that deal with branching time.
And those are sort
of an extension
of linear temporal logic.
They add a few
other operators that
allow you to reason
over multiple paths.
But for our purposes,
we're just going
to be using the
linear time model.
So kind of as a recap,
what linear temporal logic
involves--
we're using this
linear time model.
Another important distinction
is that we're actually
going to be talking about
infinite sequences of states.
So instead of us just reasoning
up until a certain goal
condition is met, we're
thinking about systems
that could theoretically
keep transitioning over time,
over and over and
over into the future.
So if you have one of
these state machines,
you could think,
at each time step,
it's going to visit
the new state.
And if you give it
enough time, it's
just going to generate an
infinite sequence of states.
And we can actually
express properties
that can hold over an
infinite number of states,
not just the discrete
number of states
that we might usually
think of to reach a goal.
And linear temporal
logic can actually
be modified to work with
discrete set of states.
It just requires an
additional operator.
But the ability to reason about
infinite sequences of states
gives us a lot of power in
talking about guarantees
for our system, regardless
of how much time we're
talking about it.
Finally, all the
operators we're going
to be looking at
in our logic system
are what we call
forward-looking conditions.
So when we're
given a state we're
going to reasoning
about what's going
to happen in the future for
a potentially infinite amount
of time in the future.
There's sort of a symmetric
version of this logic that
reasons about the past.
So for example, we can say--
talk about guarantees that
something will eventually
happen in the future--
there's sort of a
symmetric version where
we can talk about,
given a certain state,
we can guarantee that
something had eventually
happened in the past.
But for us in that we're
going to focus on planning--
we're typically planning about
what to do in the future,
and it makes more sense for us
to use this future of updating
the set for operators.
And so I guess one
little nuance here
that I sort of pointed
out in the previous slide
is that because we're using
a linear model of time
and not a branching
model of time,
we're going to be expressing
properties that happen over
a single path of states, and
not properties that happen over
several path of states.
So finally I'm just going
to talk about a couple
of the main application
for linear temporal logic
before Ellie will
dive in, and actually
talk more about the
semantics and syntax of how
we use this logic.
So the first menus is
verification and model
checking.
We can use this
linear temporal logic
to create guarantees
about a system,
and formally verify it for a
couple different properties.
For example, we can talk about
the safety of the system.
We can say, over the
course of this system,
we guarantee that
it will never enter
a state of a certain condition.
We could also talk about the
maintenance of properties.
So over the entire
lifetime of this system,
we guarantee that a certain
condition will always hold.
The other main application
for temporal logic,
the one that we're going to be
focusing on, is for planning.
And this planning
using these temporally
extended goals that
I've been talking about,
and it actually extends
nicely to talking
about temporally
extended preferences.
So this is given that we have
a number of different paths
that could reach a goal, we
can actually look at all those
and see which paths
satisfy certain conditions
over the sequence of states,
and use those conditions
as a way of choosing
which ones we prefer.
So with that, Ellie is now
going to talk about some
of the syntax of
linear temporal logic.
ELLIE: Hi guys.
My name is Ellie, and
I'm going to be talking
about the syntax of LTL.
So an LTL formula is
a series of states.
And at each state, you can
have various propositions
than can be either
true or false.
So for example-- is it OK
if I erase this, Steve?
STEVE: Yeah.
Go ahead.
ELLIE: So for example you can
have a [INAUDIBLE] animation
show that has a series of
states that goes on to infinity.
And at each state you
can have propositions
that are either true or false.
So the traffic could
be red could be
an example for a proposition.
We could be stopped, et cetera.
And there's various
logical operators
that we can apply
to these formulas--
these sets of states,
and we can determine
if these logical operators
are either true or false
about each set of
states-- each formula.
So there's the not operator,
the or operator, the and,
the implies, if and only and,
and like I said, the state--
each proposition of [INAUDIBLE]
can either be true or false.
So just to go through
some examples of these,
the logical operator
true says that--
essentially what the operator
true says is it's not saying,
oh, this state is true.
The operator just
true says that there
are states for all infinity.
So true is always true.
So no matter what you
had for your state here,
the logical operator true holds.
However, when you talk
about the logical operator
true with respect to a certain
state or a certain proposition,
then it can either
be true or false.
So for example, here, the
logical operator red light
is true at the first state.
If this was green, then
the logical operator red
would be false at
the first state.
Does that make sense?
All right.
One important thing to note
about the logical o operators
is that they just apply
to the very first state
in your statement.
So when we're discussing
logical operators,
we haven't gotten
to the point where
we can express
temporal information
about our sequence of states.
The next operator is, not.
So as you can see
here, the traffic light
is read at the first state.
So the traffic
light's not green.
Hold, because the
proposition green is not
true at the first state.
And the logical operator,
and, at this first state
is we're at the red light,
and we're getting gas.
And so both that
we're at the red light
and that we're getting gas
holds for the first state.
And then the operator,
or, essentially says--
I guess a lot of this
is probably review
for you guys--
logical operators--
but essentially if
you have red or green
then you could either have
the traffic light be red
or the traffic light be
green at the first state.
And as long as one of those
two hold, or both of them
hold, then it's true.
And one thing to note about
or lies in if and only
if these can be re-written with
just the logical operators,
and, and, not.
So another way of
expressing red and green
is to say that you can't have
the scenario where both is not
red, and it's not green.
And I'm not going to go
over that for, implies,
and, if and only if, just
for the sake of time.
So that's just a review
of the logical operators,
and now we're going to go
into the temporal operators.
So when we're talking
about our autonomous car,
what are some useful
temporal operators?
Because up until
now, we just are
describing of the first
state in our sequence, which
isn't really useful
if we want to talk
about the entire set of
sequences [INAUDIBLE] states.
So what do you guys think are
some mutual things that we
want to be able to describe?
I know Ben touched on some
of them at the beginning,
but if you guys could
recount some of them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: State connection.
ELLIE: Mm-hmm.
State connections.
So exactly.
So if I'm in a state
right now, might there
be concerns about
the next state?
Is that kind of like
what you're saying?
Exactly.
Yeah.
So next is one of
the things that we
might be concerned
about, the next state.
Are there any other tings
you guys can think of?
AUDIENCE: Always or [INAUDIBLE]
ELLIE: Yes, exactly.
Always.
So like Ben said, we always
want to follow the speed limit.
We always want to be
under 35 miles an hour,
or whatever the speed limit is.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Until.
ELLIE: Until.
Yep.
So like he said, you
want to be stopped
until the light turns green.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Eventually.
ELLIE: Eventually.
Yep.
So we eventually
want to get gas.
And eventually.
Any other things?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: At this state.
ELLIE: At this state.
Yep.
And so, at this state, is kind
of what the logical operators
were doing at the
beginning, but I
agree that's something we
have to be able to express.
So that's not a specific
temporal operator,
but it's included
in the logical one,
so I'll just write
it up here for you.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question?
ELLIE: Uh huh.
AUDIENCE: So the
logical operators,
are they acting on the-- so
they're acting for a state?
They're not acting
on the entire chain.
ELLIE: They act for a state.
And so if you just wrote
the logical operators,
just by the
definition of LTL, it
means let's just
analyze the first state
and see if it's true.
And so it won't tell us
anything about the third state
or the fourth state or the
second state, which is why we
have to look at the next state.
So yeah.
Any other questions?
OK.
So like you said, next
is an important one.
So right here we consider OK,
the next light will be green.
And until is the one
that she mentioned,
so the light will be red until
it becomes green eventually.
So the light will eventually
at some point in the future
turn green.
So you might be waiting at
the red light for a long time,
but eventually it's going
to turn green for us.
The light will
always be red, so I
guess you're stuck at the
traffic light for a long time,
or globally-- that's
another name for always.
And lastly, this on is a
little bit less intuitive.
So what this is
saying is the light
will always be red until
another circumstance coincides
with the same state.
So the light will be always
red until the car gets gas.
And then after it gets its
gas, then the red is released,
and the light can be either
green or red after that.
So you have red red red red red
until we have both red and gas.
And then it can be green or
it can be red [INAUDIBLE]
it's not constrained
to being red.
Does that make sense?
That one's a little bit
less intuitive, so--
is that good?
OK.
All right.
So now that we've gone
over just the intuitive
understanding of that,
I'm going to give you
the actual syntax for that.
So x is representative of next.
So in the first state, we
don't care if p is true.
p could be not true,
p could be true.
It doesn't matter.
But in the second
state, the next one
up in the first state, p,
has to hold in order for xp
to be a true statement about
our sequence of states.
So what do you guys
think if I wrote this?
What would that mean?
AUDIENCE: Different
state [INAUDIBLE]
ELLIE: Yep.
So this one over here?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
[INAUDIBLE]
ELLIE: Yeah.
Perfect.
All right.
The until operator.
The until operator essentially
says, like Ben said,
we're stopped until
the light is green.
So if you have p
until w, you just p
has to be true at every state
until w, and after that point,
p can be whatever
it wants to be.
p eventually, or
future operator,
says that at some point in
the future we will get gas.
However it's important to note--
I know when we talked
about getting gas we said,
oh, we have to always get gas
at some point in the future,
but the future eventually
operator is just
at one point in the future.
So once you get gas, you
don't have to get it again.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: On the
previous slide you
had a not at the
bottom that said that w
is required to become true.
Does that mean an
until operator also
implies a future operator on w?
ELLIE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right.
[INAUDIBLE]
ELLIE: Yep.
But it's the added
condition that p
will be true until the w.
AUDIENCE: But like whenever
you use until, you say p
until w that you'd
also have to add
at some point in the
future [INAUDIBLE]
ELLIE: Yeah.
Yep, you're right.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean, it would
be possible that this stays p,
right?
ELLIE: It could.
Yeah.
But then if your system-- that
would be totally fine if you
had your system just be p, but
then the operator p until w
wouldn't hold unless you had a
w at some point in that sequence
of p's.
Does that make sense.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] I guess it does
if that's the way to do it,
but it doesn't make
sense [INAUDIBLE] it.
ELLIE: So you're
saying that we could
have a bunch of p's, right?
Is that what you're saying?
And I'm saying that this
is a fine state to have.
You can have whatever you want.
And we're just analyzing if
a sentence is true about it.
So this statement,
it's not true--
or, sorry.
I'm saying that it's not
true that we have p and lw
because there's
no w in our state.
But if we add in a w somewhere
and we keep all the p's, then
it's true because we have
p up until we get to a w.
Did that make sense?
AUDIENCE: It made sense
that that's the rule,
but it doesn't make
sense to me why.
Because the
statement [INAUDIBLE]
true and if w never appears.
You have p until w,
which never happened.
ELLIE: Yeah.
If w never happened,
then it wouldn't be true.
AUDIENCE: I mean, technically,
for the English language
it would be true.
AUDIENCE: I guess it's not--
AUDIENCE: If you have
p out to infinity,
and you never have w's.
p until w is true.
AUDIENCE: p until anything
is true [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Like if
you say that I'm
hungry until I eat,
and you never eat,
then you will always be hungry.
ELLIE: Oh, I see.
So that makes sense
in a logical sense,
but that's not how
it's described in LTL.
PROFESSOR: There's
also an operator that's
sort of unofficial
called the weak until,
and that's sort of saying
p until w, or always p.
So that kind of gets
rid of the condition
that it reaches w at some point.
AUDIENCE: It aligns more
with the English, too.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
ELLIE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But just the
until operator on its own
is just sort of
like a strong until.
ELLIE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So it adds the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's fine.
ELLIE: OK.
PROFESSOR: This is
the way it works.
ELLIE: Yeah.
Sometimes-- yeah, I get
confused about this sometimes.
I'll be like, why
they necessarily
[? chose any of these, ?]
but, OK.
And then the globally
one, which we
said-- this is the one that
you were just describing here
[INAUDIBLE] when
you were talking
about the p at every
single state in the future.
And then the release
operator is you
have to have p until you
have w, but p and w also
have to share the same state
when they switch from--
so in until, you don't
have to have the p here,
but with release, you have
to have the p and w occur
in the same state.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
OK.
So just like before, operators
can be described using not
and and.
The future, released, and
the globally operators
can also be described using
other temporal operators.
And so just as an exercise, can
any of you guys tell me which--
these are not in order--
which of these line up
with the other-- like, whichever
ones they line up with.
And I'll give you guys
like three minutes
to just think about it, and then
we'll work through it together
on the board.
All right, so have
any of you guys
thought about which ones
might correlate to which ones?
Does anyone have
any suggestions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The first
one's the top one.
ELLIE: This one is the top one.
That's exactly right.
So let's continue
this state again.
So the statement, true,
doesn't say anything
about what the propositions are.
It's just something that's
true for all states, right?
So if we're saying,
true until pi,
that means that you
can have whatever
you want until p occurs.
So does that make sense that,
at some point in the future,
p has to occur, exactly because
we had the strong until, right.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
You guys want to see
some [INAUDIBLE]??
All right and now
what about this one?
We have not as not p.
So this is saying that
at some point, if you
can't get a p set at
some point in the future,
you don't have p.
So what do you think
that would correspond to?
If at some point
in the future, you
can't have the situation
where there's not p.
AUDIENCE: The third one.
ELLIE: The third one?
[INAUDIBLE] So that
would be if you
have p at every
single state, then
you would never have a situation
where you don't have p, right?
And so that leaves
this last one.
You don't have a scenario where
you have not p until not w.
So if you have not--
OK.
It's still a little hard.
But I'll come back to
that one at the end, OK?
But it's just important to
remember that you can describe
these operators
with similar to them
so that your
planner doesn't have
to deal with the global operator
or these operators-- eventually
operator, it can have less
[INAUDIBLE] to deal with.
So yeah, you guys were right.
Perfect.
And then this is just a recap
of the different operators
and the other ways that
you can express them.
And so there's a few
more really cool things
that you can do combining
these different operators,
and the first is that--
remember when Ben was describing
that we need to get gas?
And we need to get
it in the future,
but even after we
get gas, we're going
to have to get it again
some time in the future.
So it's important that
we can describe something
that happens infinitely often.
And the way that we describe
that is saying that we always
have the scenario where you
will eventually reach p.
So I'm trying to think of
another way to describe that,
but does that make sense
that right now in the future,
I'm going to get gas.
And even after I get that gas,
I will eventually in the future
also need to get gas again,
because your car will always
be needing to get gas.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
And then eventually
forever is another scenario
that's important to describe.
So let's say that the
traffic light will eventually
turn green forever.
We need to be able to say that
at some point in the future,
although we don't know when, the
traffic light will turn green.
So the future operator says that
at some point in the future,
you will have
something come true.
And so at this state, p becomes
true, but the global operators
that happened from this
state forever afterwards,
which is saying that you
eventually will always
have this state B be true.
Do you guys have any
questions on that?
Did I explain that good enough.
AUDIENCE: It seems weird to me
that the gas tank is becoming
this occasional temporal
operator instead of just
like the state that
we actually have gas,
would just be the logical
thing that [INAUDIBLE]
ELLIE: Oh, yeah, I--
AUDIENCE: Why is the act of
getting gas showing up here
like that, versus just, you
always need quantity of gas.
ELLIE: That's true.
We do always need
some quantity of gas,
and you would describe
that, like you said,
just with the always
operator, but I
guess my action
of getting gas is
I was thinking of actually
driving up to the gas station
and filling it up with gas.
And if you didn't do
that, you wouldn't
be able to always have gas.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Right,
so I would think
that always having gas would
make [INAUDIBLE] of you plan
[INAUDIBLE]
ELLIE: Yeah, and depending
on how you make your model,
you definitely could do
that, and that definitely
would satisfy the condition.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --the usual
way to deal with it?
ELLIE: Well, it depends
on the situation.
Maybe you [INAUDIBLE]
want to say
at some point in the future,
the light will always be green,
because you want to make sure
that cars can go through,
and there's a
difference between red,
and some point it will
be green in the future.
So it really depends
on your model and how--
I think the way
you're saying it,
where you always
want to have gas,
and the proposition gas is how
much gas you have in your tank,
and if you have it
or don't, then I
think that that would be a
really good way to model it,
too.
AUDIENCE: Because this way, if
you said, I have to get gas.
I planned it for next week, but
I've run out of gas this week.
Do you know what I mean, like,
you have to somehow be tracking
the quantity of gas also.
ELLIE: I agree.
I agree.
I was just using it as an
example to explain the concept,
but I agree that that
definitely probably
could be better with more work.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think in both cases
what it could represent is
having gas all the time,
or explicitly saying that you're
going to be in gas stations
eventually--
always eventually.
It depends on how--
maybe we'd want to always
have gas from a station,
and also getting gas from it.
So depending on how you want
to model it, but I think
both will work.
AUDIENCE: So infinite
and often, doesn't really
care about how frequently--
ELLIE: Yeah, it doesn't
care how frequently.
AUDIENCE: But [INAUDIBLE]
for instance something
that happens every 60 years.
My system lifetime
server is 30 years,
which means something
happens only once.
So in this case,
infinite and often,
how can you filter
a switch operator
could be the same, right?
ELLIE: Can you repeat
that again [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So for
instance something
happens every 60 years.
My system lifetime
goes to 30 years.
After 30 years, I have to
get a re-up on the system.
Then so during this [INAUDIBLE]
only one thing happened.
And so it happens
off into infinity,
but in the lifetime
of the system,
it only happened
once, and therefore
in this condition, the
infinite and often should
be set the same as the future,
right, in the current state.
Something happened
in the future,
I would say something
could never happen again.
ELLIE: Kind of.
So when you're talking
about a system that's
dying after 30 years, the LTL
doesn't actual model something
that ends.
It would model
something to infinity,
although there is an
extension to LTL that
can incorporate that into it,
having it have an actual end
goal state.
And I think in that case,
then infinitely often would
be different, and would--
I don't know exactly how that
would find that situation.
Do you know, Ben?
I know you had kind of--
BEN: So there's something called
metric temporal logic, which
associates a time scale of
each of these operators.
So I think you'd have to
use that if you were trying
to express that you had to
always meet those conditions
still within your lifetime.
You could have some sort of
qualifier to these operators
to specify an actual time
[INAUDIBLE] where that operator
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So which
would you file
for the instance infinitely
often [INAUDIBLE]
scenario something at a
little bit more frequent
of a general system
by the time, right.
Now we have something you
know [INAUDIBLE] 100 years ago
for years.
BEN: You know, it's
important that the LTL
we're explaining here is only
dealing with infinite states.
So I agree, it's
a little bit-- you
have to think about
that process of how
do apply something that goes
on forever to a real system.
It obviously doesn't
model correctly.
AUDIENCE: There has
to be a way to--
I mean the future thing,
if he has a system that
lasts 30 years, and
you say future p,
somewhere in your
design of the system
is going to say that the
constraint on future p
is that it has to happen
within 30 years, right?
Because future p
here, for getting gas,
has to happen before
I run out of gas.
It's not just-- this
representation says it just
happens in the future, but
somewhere in your constraint
checking, it's going
to say, hey, we
didn't get gas in this
plan soon enough, right?
ELLIE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Somehow.
ELLIE: Yes, that's
definitely true.
And these are just tools
to help you model it,
but it's definitely not the
entire model of your system
obviously, and so I agree
that we definitely would
have to incorporate that in.
And for finance systems you
have to account for that.
And that's why they have
the extension of LTL which
is the finance systems,
which we can certainly
drop a link of of
the papers, and where
we got the information, to
the class if you guys would
like that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think you
guys have done a very good job
of answering the questions.
The three extensions
to LTL that I've
found to be the most
relevant kinds of things
that we're doing is
metric temporal logic,
which is the first one
that you mentioned,
also to be able to have it over
bounded time, which is related,
and you mentioned.
And then the last one is
to deal with uncertainty,
and is then a problem of
linear temporal logic.
ELLIE: OK.
Cool.
All right.
So I meant to have this
as two separate slides,
but what are some true
statements about LTL
that you guys can tell
me about to look at this,
or do, and explain
why if you look at it.
OK, so why is the next red true?
AUDIENCE: The next
step is slow down.
ELLIE: Yep, exactly.
Because the next one is red.
Why is it true that in the
future, that it's green?
[INAUDIBLE]
Because in the
future, it's green.
And why is it true that
there's red until green?
AUDIENCE: It keeps being
red until it's green.
ELLIE: Exactly.
So it makes sense
that if all of these
are true, that this culmination
of the and statements
between all of them
is also true, right?
And so you could do
that with or as well,
or you could do that with--
if you had sequences
behind here,
you could put a future
around this whole thing,
and it would be true that
at some point in the future,
all of this would hold.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Why keep it red there?
Your red is the next step.
ELLIE: Yep.
Exactly.
I was just saying if you
had more in the past,
and you were considering
it from the previous--
All right so now
Nadia's going to talk
about expressing LTL in PDDL3.
So Ben and Ellie have
guided through how
expressive LTL formulation is.
I'm going to formulate the
LTL in a classical planner
like PDDL3.
Now I'm using PDDL3, which is an
composed extension of PDDL2.2,
which supports some
of the LTL operators.
So these are the basic
operators that you
can use to express
the constraints
and goals of your plan.
So you have at end,
always, sometimes, within,
at-most-once, sometime-after,
sometime-before, always-within,
and hold-during.
So again, now here is a numeric
controls that you can specify,
and the ellipses represents an
already-existing [INAUDIBLE]
goal.
This is a goal description--
[INAUDIBLE]
So some of the operators
may look familiar to you,
because they can also be used to
express the constraint in STN,
the Simple Temporal Network,
that we learned in class.
And there are some
operators that
are unique to LTL
or other kinds,
like metric temporal network,
like always, for example.
So now we are going
to take a look
at how you can express
the operators using
the PDDL3 language.
So we can use, within one
occurrence to the next,
because there is no
explicit next in the PDDL3.
And you use always
until to express until.
And in the future, you
use sometimes after,
and globally, you
can use always.
And for release,
since it can always
be omega or always until
omega when you see p.
You can use all costs, too,
although this [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, let's see some examples.
So if your goal is to have
the traffic light turn
red in the next
state, you would want
to formulate it using
within one occurrence,
the traffic light
would turn red.
And let's take a look at a
more complicated example.
So if you want to model a
goal saying that the traffic
light would be green until
it turns red, at which point
it would be red forever.
So this is temporal
logic of predicates
that express this goal.
And then if you want to
model that using PDDL,
there is a direct mapping.
You can see the direct
mapping between the predicates
and the PDDL.
So this is basically
saying, it would always
be green until it turns red.
And turning red implies
it will always turn red.
So next, [? Arleese ?] will tell
us how to map between the LTL
to PDDL with a
Buchi Automata which
is a specialized automata.
GUEST SPEAKER: Cool.
So I'm [? Arleese. ?] I have
bridged the gap between LTL
and the planning world.
So this is kind of
the framework for how
you would go from
taking a problem
with temporally extended
goals all the way to a plan.
So as you can kind
of imagine from what
Ben and Ellie were
talking about,
LTL is pretty expressive.
You can express a lot of
different types of goals
that include more temporal
properties than just a time
window for a goal
to be completed.
So once we have a kind
of defined problem
with these temporary
extended goals,
then you want to model it in
a language like LTL or PDDL.
So if you have a
language like PDDL,
and you have a planner that
can do an algorithm called
progression, which I'll
talk about a little later,
you can go directly to a plan.
Basically how progression works
is it's kind of an algorithm
that tells you when
you're analyzing a state,
and you're analyzing
LTL-like formulas that
are true in a specific
state, how to push formulas
that you need to evaluate
later on to the next state,
and how to keep track
of things that you
need to continue to evaluate for
satisfaction in future states.
Another way you can do this
is by taking LTL formulations
and translating them
into Buchi Automata.
So Buchi Automata are
basically finite state machines
that are extended to handle an
infinite sequence of states.
And I'll get into more about
how Buchi Automata work.
After you have a
Buchi Automata, you
can then translate
that into PDDL2,
which you guys are
all familiar with,
and then that PDDL2 can be used
from the classical planner,
and get a plan.
So a little bit more
about Buchi Automata.
Again, like I said,
it's an extension
of a finite state machine.
Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: Why would have a Buchi
Automata when you could just
use a planner that will go from
PDDL3 straight to the plan?
GUEST SPEAKER: I guess
it just depends on how--
what kind of planners
we have access to,
what other systems you have.
It's done both ways.
So PDDL3 is still kind of
new, and so there's not
a lot of planners that actually
have progression and can
handle PDDL3.
AUDIENCE: And it's also the case
that the particular algorithms
that are trying to either be
verification or planning, maybe
exploiting particular properties
of the Buchi Automaton,
as opposed to the properties
of the native language.
GUEST SPEAKER: So you guys are
all familiar with regular state
machines.
Buchi Automata has a
very similar formulation.
Some slight differences--
you have a set of states,
you have an initial state, and
you have a transition relation,
and then you have a set
of accepting states.
These accepting
states are essentially
what replaces finite states
in the state machine.
We also have a set of
symbols that are again simply
the transitions between states.
So what an accepting state
is, is a Buchi Automata
can only be valid if the
sequence of transitions
visits an accepting state
an infinite amount of times.
So I'll get into
a couple examples.
So let's say you want to model
the ticking-tocking of a clock.
This is just a regular
finite state machine.
As you can see, after some
number of ticks and tocks,
you get into S2,
and you're in S2
because you can be in
transition only [INAUDIBLE]
So you're in S2 basically
forever once you get to S2.
So we can model this
as a Buchi Automata
by making S2 an accepted state.
This example, making
it a Buchi Automata,
doesn't really do
anything for you.
It's just kind of to illustrate
what the accepting state does.
So the accepting words are
a sequence of transitions.
In this case it would be
an infinite combination
of ticks and tocks that would
make this Buchi Automata valid.
Does that make sense.
Questions about that?
Here's another
example, for example,
if I have changed what
my accepting state was.
So if our accepting
state was S1,
I now have to visit S1 an
infinite amount of times
for this Buchi
Automata to be valid.
That means the
only valid sequence
of transitions I could
have is tock tick tick tick
tick for an infinite
amount of times.
So you can kind of
represent different things
and different
sequences of inputs
you might want to have based on
which accepting state you use.
This is another example.
If you wanted your clock to be
tick tock tick tock tick tock,
you can have more than
one accepting state,
and now I have to visit S0 and
S1 an infinite amount of times
if I want this Buchi
Automata to be valid.
So then the sequence
of transitions I get
is tick tock tick
tock tick tock.
Does anyone have any questions
to really think about
in general with Buchi Automata?
OK.
It might help to see how we
model LTL as Buchi Automata.
So here's an example of
of these LTL formulas
modeled as a Buchi Automata.
I guess take a few
minutes and see
if you can get which
one this one might be.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
Just so that everyone can kind
of see that, and future events,
we remember that means
that eventually p
has to be true at least once.
So from any sort of input
state, you go to S0,
and then I do have amount
p for some amount of time,
but as soon as I have
p, I have to get to p,
because I have to be
in my subject state
an infinite amount of times.
So I have to execute
p at some point
to get to my accepting state
for this Buchi Automata
to be valid.
And then once I'm
at S1, I can have
any other amount of inputs.
I'll always be in S1, and that's
what the true label means.
AUDIENCE: And it's
also something
stronger, right,
which is you could--
it's eventually globally?
GUEST SPEAKER: Right.
Yeah, so actually in this
case, after it gets here,
my input could be anything.
So this basically just says
that for my initial state,
I have to execute p
at least once to get
to this accepting state,
and once I'm there,
I can be there--
I'm always there.
Any input will believe me in S1.
AUDIENCE: So just to make this
clear for myself and maybe
for others, the
data string executed
that's at R state something
that's on the loop.
If you go from s0 to
s0, that's essentially
saying that one of
the nodes is not p.
If you go from s0 to s1, it's
saying that one of the nodes
is p.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you
go from s1 to s1
and take whatever it would
be because you set it true.
AUDIENCE: So if you put p
where the true is right now,
then you you won't
have to go through.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's what I missed.
By the way, you guys
have 25 more minutes.
GUEST SPEAKER: So that's
what we talked about.
This is future.
So the accepted
sequence of propositions
would be not to not p.
Then you have p.
Then it can be anything
after you get to p.
And then in this case, for
Buchi Automata states, which
are like [INAUDIBLE],, slightly
different than the LTL states
we've been talking about.
In this case, you're in s0.
And then once you get to
s1, you're forever in s1.
So globally, looks
pretty similar to this.
Take a few minutes
to think about how
I might change this Buchi
Automata to [INAUDIBLE]
globally after [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, exactly.
So you have initially,
your first state by your n
because p has to be
true forever after you
get to this first state.
You have an
accepting state in p.
You can also model not p.
If you want to,
you can also just
have this single see
which would encapsulate
exactly what Buchi is.
This is how you go from
LTL to Buchi Automata.
In a real-world scenario, we
have multiple LTL formulas all
combined.
You're Buchi Automata are
going to look a little bit more
complicated than this.
Try multiple accepting states.
There's a full
weighted model of what
an LTL is trying to represent.
AUDIENCE: If we have the not
p transition out of there,
Like it's possible you can come
into s0 to accept the Buchi
Automata because it
would go to s1, right?
GUEST SPEAKER: Accepting a
Buchi Automata after that,
it's a little confusing.
A Buchi Automata is only
valid if the infinite sequence
of states satisfies it.
If I were to go the
p instead of not p,
my sequence would accept a
transition of p, p, not p.
Then that would not
be a valid sequence
of transition for
this Buchi Automata
because I'm transitioning
out of my accepting state,
which I need to have been in for
at least the amount of times.
And there's no way I
can get back to success.
Also, a more defined algorithm
[INAUDIBLE] an intuitive way
to build a Buchi Automata,
or is an algorithm.
The other one that's
most popularly used
was developed by [INAUDIBLE].
This is a pseudocode
version of the algorithm.
We go from LTL to Buchi.
As you've noticed, it
actually uses progression,
which is something that planners
that take PDDL use to generate
plans.
An important thing
to note, which
I won't go into too much
detail, this algorithm
generates a generalized
Buchi Automata,
which you then change to
a simple Buchi Automata.
The difference is, the
generalized Buchi Automata
has a set of sets
of accepting states.
For a generalized Buchi
Automata to be accepted,
you need to visit
an accepting state
in each one of those
sets of accepting states.
At least one of those
states has to be listed.
For a simple Buchi
Automata, you only
have one set of
accepting states.
And you can visit any one of
those for the Buchi Automata
to be valid.
On the translation between
those two is a little bit more
complicated.
We'll have paper in the
preference that will
walk through how to do that.
But we're not going
to do that now.
This is a progression algorithm.
Basically, it just tells you
how if have a LTL formula f
and some current state N--
and usually they
involve some time step
because we're in the real
world and we can't really
model infinite amount
of time, and we
have to make it discrete.
So we have some time step,
which means successive state.
How do you push certain LTL
formulas onto next states
to be evaluated later?
For example, I'll take
this next f as an example.
So if f was a next f
of some LTL formula,
you need to append that
formula to the next state
to be evaluated
in the next state
to see if that's going
to be true or not.
Similar things for LTL.
And I won't go through
this [INAUDIBLE]
it's here for reference.
The next step to this process
is going from Buchi Automata,
that's a PDDL2.
This process is confusing.
At least it is confusing
for me to understand.
The first thing I'll say is
that Buchi states are not
equivalent to
traditional PDDL states.
In a PDDL state, if
you have two states,
you have the same propositions
that are true and false,
those states are identical.
In the Buchi Automata,
that's not necessarily true.
In the Buchi Automata
you also have
to encapsulate which
transitions you can make out
of each Buchi state.
So s1 and s2 couldn't have
the same set of propositions
that are [INAUDIBLE] hold.
But out of s1--
actually, back up.
This is the Buchi Automata
for FutureGlobally,
which is what [INAUDIBLE]
was talking about.
So if I enter an
f1, the star means
I can have any transition
that I want in s1.
At some point, I
make the transition p
and whatever the s2, I have
to take transition p forever.
However, if I get a sequence
of inputs, let's say I get p
and then b, and p
again, and then p again,
it's not clear if
I'm in s1 or s2
because in s1 I can execute
any kind of state I want.
In s1 I can execute any
transition I want in s1.
2 I have to execute only p.
So if I got a sequence of p's,
I could be in either state.
You need something else to
activate PDDL2 to basically
to determine which state
you're and which transitions
you can make from that state.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
So there's two ways
we can transform
PDDL2 to encapsulate what a
Buchi Automata encapsulates.
The first thing
is you can create
new actions that can encapsulate
the allowable transitions
of each state.
So basically, for
every action you
have in your
traditional PDDL, you
have create a repetitive action
for each one of these states
so you know exactly
which transitions
you can take out of that state.
This can get long
because you have
to make a new action
for every single one
of these states for every
action that you want to take.
That is one way you can do it.
Another way you can do it is
introducing derived predicates.
Derived predicates
are predicates
that don't depend
the actions at all
and just depend on some
other formula in your plan.
For example, we can
have a derived predicate
that explicitly tells
you whether you're in s1
or whether you're in s2.
And you can use these
predicates in your actions
in PDDL2 to make sure, even
though which state, x1 or x2,
you're in in your
Buchi Automata.
And then, in your
formulation of your plan,
you set your final state to be
one of the accepting states.
I guess that answers one
of the questions, though,
how you go from being
infinite to finite.
The accepting state
is usually what
you place as your final state.
AUDIENCE: Then in the
derived predicates,
you're purely in
the pre-conditions?
Or do they also
appear in the effects.
GUEST SPEAKER: They also
appear in the effects
because you need to know how
to transition out of s1 to s2.
So you'd likely have a
derived predicate for both s1
and a derived predicate for s2.
And that is also a lot of work
to add to the PDDL2 problem.
But it's definitely
shorter than the first way.
And it definitely
encapsulates everything,
by the Buchi
Automata [INAUDIBLE]
Does anyone have any
questions about that?
AUDIENCE: So you're
changing the action then?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
You're changing
the action but you
don't need make a new
action for every state.
In the first
formulation, let's say
I have some traditional
action, like move blue block,
or something.
I have to create a
move block action
for each one of these
states because I
need to know exactly
which transitions
I can take out of that action.
AUDIENCE: In the second example?
GUEST SPEAKER: And
in the second one
I can just have one move block.
But in my move block I'll
have a derived predicate
that tells me which state I'm
in when I execute that action.
The number of actions
you have to write
is less because
you explicitly have
predicates that are telling
you which state that you're in.
Now I'm going to
hand it over to--
if there are no more questions--
hand it over to Mark.
And he's going to talk
about preferences.
MARK: We're getting
a little low on time.
Now I'll transition
to talking about--
we talked about
temporally extended goals.
We said that goals are things
that always have to be true.
So now let's talk
about preferences.
Preferences are things
that don't necessarily
have to be true, but are things
that you'd like to be true.
In the classical
planning problem,
we can formulate it like that.
We can set a state S, set a
state s0, a set of operators,
and a set of goal states.
The problem is transition
from the initial states
and any state.
But those are goal states
using the operators [INAUDIBLE]
Preference based
planning problem
introduces a
traditional field R,
which is a partial or total
relation expressing preferences
between plans.
And this is a little
preference symbol right there.
That tells you, if
there are multiple plans
you need to
accomplish your goal,
which one do you want to use.
And again, preferences
are properties
that are desired but not
necessarily required.
There are two [INAUDIBLE]
different types
of preference languages,
quantitative and qualitative.
As you would expect, in
quantitative languages,
we actually assign a numeric
value to the different plans
in order to compare them.
So these plans are a weight
of four, and a weight of two,
and that tells you
which one to prefer.
Here are some
languages that do that.
For qualitative
languages, they actually
just have a plan
with this property
is preferred to this other
plan with this property.
But we don't actually
know any information that
knows how much we
prefer one to the other,
or something like that.
An important element
of this is when
you have quantitative languages,
they're totally comparable.
Any two sets of plans
you can determine
which one is preferred.
Whereas in
qualitative languages,
you could have situations
where plan one is preferred
to plan two, and plan one
is also preferred to plan 3,
but that doesn't give you any
information about whether plan
two is preferred to plan three.
So it's a little bit less
expressive [INAUDIBLE]..
To go into how you actually
express preferences in PDDL3,
like we talked about
temporally extended goals,
there is a PDDL3
syntax to do this.
There's a preference label here
that you can put on fluents
to represent things you prefer.
And then there's a
function call is-violated
that essentially returns
the number of times
that any fluent that
has a preference label
was not satisfied in your plan.
For example, if you
have a preference,
"Traffic light is green
until it turns red."
Here's our PDDL3 template.
It extended this
kid's preference,
in which we label it with
a preference label here.
And this is just a name.
And then or plan tries to
minimize the number of times
that this preference
is violated.
That's one way to express
preferences directly in PDDL3.
So now we talk about LDP.
LDP is a different
language that is
quite expressive in terms
of types of preferences
you can represent.
It is a quantitative
language, which
means we're going to have
weights for each of our plans
to express our preferences.
We can actually express the
strength of the preference.
So Goal A is preferred twice or
three times as much as Goal B.
It's an extension of an
older language named PP.
Here is the paper if you
want to actually check out
these details.
The formulas are
constructed hierarchically.
I'll go through quickly
how we actually construct
these preference formulas.
The lowest level is called a
Basic Design Formula, or BDF.
That just expresses
our temporally extended
proposition.
So this is just a
straight up LTL,
basically, that we saw
in the first section
of the presentation.
I'm going to use that
I'm cooking dinner
example for these slides.
In this case, we always
use the future operators.
At some point, I might want
to cook this program plan.
Maybe I want to order
takeout to eat dinner.
And then I have some eating
spaghetti or eating pizza.
Those are two different
things, two different options
that I could have in my plan.
I don't have to have
either of those.
Those are just options
that I could have.
That's the lowest level.
The next level is called Atomic
Preference Formulas, or APFs.
There are where we express our
preferences between the BDFs
that we formed in
the previous slide.
So in this example
I'm using weight,
specifically to
represent preference,
with lower weight
being preferred.
Here we're saying, we prefer
to cook over ordering takeout.
This is you where
you have to cook,
this is where you
have to order takeout.
And we apply weights to
those two expressions.
The first one's
preferred, and how much
it is preferred over this plan.
And here is you prefer to eat
spaghetti over eating pizza.
So that's the second level.
Third levels called General
Purpose Formulas, or GPS.
These are where we can do
conjunctions or disjunctions,
or qualification of
our previous formulas.
So for example, if
we want to say--
because in the previous
slides we had two APFs.
We had prefer to cook and
prefer to eat spaghetti.
And here we can
express that we really
don't care which one of
these we want to satisfy.
You can think of
this as we actually
tried to satisfy APF
at the lowest weight.
So if we have this
"or" operating here,
that means that our planner
is going to try and satisfy
the lowest weight among all
these different options here,
which means that he
doesn't prefer to cook.
That's its first goal.
You can also use a handoff
rigor, for example.
And that's going to
minimize the maximum weight
against both of those options.
Basically, what's it
going to try and do--
oops-- what it's
going to try and do
is minimize the highest weight
among these two options.
So it's going to try
and cook, and then it's
going to try and eat
spaghetti versus doing
these other options.
So those are GPFs.
I'm now moving on to Aggregated
Preference Formulas, which
are the highest level.
So with APFs, these
define the order
in which our different
preferences are relaxed.
You can, of course, express a
lot of different preferences
for your planner,
but not all of them
may be achievable,
especially if you're
trying to achieve a large number
of preferences at the same.
You may not actually be able
to achieve all of those.
So how do we produce our
set in the correct order,
in the preferred order so
that our plan we end up with
isn't even the most
preferred plan?
That's what APFs like to do.
You can express, using
this preference operator.
First, I want to try and
satisfy both of these
in the previous slide.
Then if I can't, I want to
relax it so I only satisfy G2.
And then if I can't
do that, then I
want to relax it so I
only try and satisfy G1.
So that gives us the order
in which things are relaxed.
It's important here that if
you have these situations where
you can't distinguish
from one another,
or you don't really care,
we can establish some order.
So at the very
lowest type of level,
we can sort them alphabetically,
or something, just
to provide some sort of order.
This is just a review of
what I've been talking about.
BDFs are the lowest
level, which express
temporally extended
propositions.
We can apply preference
to those using APFs.
Then we can combine or join APFs
using tell preference formulas.
And finally, we can aggregate
those preference formulas
to determine the order
in which you shouldn't
relax the propositions to allow
yourself to plan it right.
So using this
scheme in LPP, we're
using both LTL syntax and
rules that we talked about
in the first section to
express temporally extended
preferences.
The plans that's actually
used to solve these types
of problems is called P Plan.
P Plans can actually handle
templates, and the preferences,
and a goal at the end, as well.
And it does basically
a best first search
among all your
different options.
It's actually one of the planner
that uses the left branch.
But the one we showed
uses progression to take
LTL formulas at each
point in the plan
and determine whether you've
satisfied those formulas
or not.
And if not, it will push
them to the next state,
so that in the next state you
can evaluate whether you've
satisfied those formulas.
That's how it prunes
the search space
and tries to always find the
most preferred plan to meet
your goal.
All right.
So that's our presentation.
Any questions from anyone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] question.
I have a question about
[INAUDIBLE] presentation.
You guys [INAUDIBLE]
and then believes omega.
Would you say that
omega has to hold
if p happens, and they have
a conjunction in one state?
ELLIE: Omega doesn't have to
hold until we [INAUDIBLE]..
Omega just has to hold
at the last state of p.
Essentially what it's
saying is omega releases p.
So once omega happened, p
has to happen at the state.
And the omega has to release p.
Now it happens, so p,
you can don't you want.
You can be true,
you can be false.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So p has to hold
until omega happens.
ELLIE: Yep.
And then omega--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: So the definition is
just switched to p [INAUDIBLE]..
ELLIE: This is an occasion.
Occasionally, you have pR omega.
But like intuitively--
AUDIENCE: It's just
the definition-- oh--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: That's all I was
wondering because then I
saw that and it was confusing.
So that's all.
OK, sorry.
ELLIE: That's fine.
MARK: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Since there
are multiple ways
to express the same formula
using the grammar, is there
any notion of canonical forms,
or a least complicated form,
or something like that?
MARK: Yeah, there is.
Typically they actually--
let me find the slide.
So to simplify the algorithms
they typically apply
the kind of reductions
that we showed in the slide
to reduce the release
and the globally
and the future down to just
the [INAUDIBLE] of an x.
Otherwise, your
algorithms going to be
able to handle fewer cases.
And then they apply
the usual rules,
trying to push nots out
to the left-hand side.
All right.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]